[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
really excited to be talking about
psychometric AI today we have a dr. avi
Guzman joining us on the show hello Alan
thanks for coming on thanks so much for
having me really appreciate it super
excited we have a lot to unpack here in
conversation for those that don't know
obvious of honor and CEO of pinpoint
predictive he's an internationally
recognized expert on heritable
psychometric traits and we are super
pumped to dive into this all right so
let's start with how you got interested
in psychometric AI yeah Wow
so would you like the short version or
the little bit medium version give us
the goes the long term yeah so I was
always a very adventurous person and
academically I started off in the field
of anthropology and I did my
undergraduate work in quechua humor
that's a Native American language spoken
in South America just an adventurous
person and you know one day I had to get
a first job and I wound up working also
in South America but work in the field
of shaping public opinion working in
some very complex political environments
post-conflict working with corporations
and with government and coming into a
very polarized society that had just
gone through a lot of internal warfare
and terrorism and I saw a lot of
extremism and I hadn't been exposed to
that before whether it was on the far
left or the far right it was before our
country became a little bit more
polarized alright
and started getting really interested in
the question of why did people have such
distorted ways of looking at the world
so sort of got into I guess what you
might call moral psychology and then
went back to graduate school at Stanford
to try to understand this but I was
doing evolutionary biology and
anthropology and the traditional answers
weren't really considered adequate from
from the point of view of that field so
I started digging deeper you know I'm
getting into feels like genetics or what
behavioral biology neuroscience you know
did and and I the one thing that I did
get some considerable training in
because these are very diverse areas was
evolutionary theory and beyond just
telling stories but you know how do you
evaluate Fitness quantitatively so
anyway long story short around I wound
up publishing a book that was about
heritable psychometric traits kind of
tying together all these really
interesting studies to understand at a
deeper level why moral psychology exists
why people have different values why
they are similar across countries what
the logic is and so I guess you could
say I was driven by a desire to find the
best data known to science to understand
people to make predictions in particular
to make forward-facing predictions at
the individual level so when you spend
years reading through yeah
probably probably hundreds I'd have to
count but probably hundreds of
peer-reviewed articles in marketing
journals and political science and the
harder Sciences psychometrics comes up
is very very valuable kind of data you
kind of think of it back then as like
that rare earth element of data it was
hard to get but this was the best data
had the most predictive power so I end
up publishing this book
and getting some considerable expertise
until I reached kind of a pivotal
pivotal point kind of a crossroads in my
career yeah so that's the first half
okay and even as you move into the
second half there's something super
interesting I want to point out this
this it's so important for us to put our
minds around the complexity of what it's
like for billions of humans to figure
out how to work together through all of
the different languages through all the
different belief systems that we have
through all the different ways that we
macro economically and geopolitically
work together it's a very complex you
know your time when you were when you
were figuring out public opinion and the
way that people's minds evolved and form
is very fascinating stuff and then when
you went further into understanding the
psychometric side of things this like
rare rare ability this rare metal that
we have precious mineral let's say above
human psyche is so interesting mm-hmm oh
thank you I certainly find an
interesting area endlessly interesting
but that's that's me maybe maybe this is
my mattress but I I agree with you so
all right so I came to this crossroads
in my career I published this a book
about heritable psychometric traits and
it got to share with a lot of different
parts of the world that got covered in
about 24 countries there's a Chinese
language version coming out pretty soon
and you know a paperback here in the US
but I realized that there were these big
economic changes happening all around
and that I was part of this right when I
was young I didn't think so much about
economic forces I was interested in
these kind of questions but maybe it's
just that you know I graduated in 2002
after the tech
bubble burst from undergrad and then I
finished my my doctoral research in 2008
so I was very strongly affected by these
economic forces and I'd also spent a lot
of time and kind of advising and in
businesses in writing as well so those
are content creation and my father is a
professional photographer incredibly
talented and thank goodness I had a
really great career but towards the tail
end I could also see kind of the field
that devaluation of content creation and
I'd read this book by Jerome Lanier that
was brilliant and it's called who owns
the future and as a book that I really
liked a lot because I felt that he had
brilliant ideas on many of the pages
don't there are some parts that uh you
know I agree with more than others but
overall like 95 percent I think
brilliant he just cuts through all the
ideology and talks about these economic
these these changes in technology from
an economic point of view and what does
it really mean and that was inspiring to
me because basically what he says and I
I would encourage everyone to read that
book because I can't possibly do it
justice by summarizing it it's it's hard
to do that and it's so much more
interesting than what I'm about to say
but basically looks at the effect on all
of these uncultured basically and people
who produce culture and the kind of
devaluation and what's happening to our
attention spans and and then on the
other hand he looks at large
aggregations of data and now there's
power there so I felt like I got caught
between these tectonic plates there were
two paths laid out before me and one was
okay you can you can do more writing or
try to create more culture and I still
have culture and I think there's ways to
do that and I have a great admiration
for for that or I spent about 10 years
researching this rare earth element of
data that was the best date if you want
to make forward-looking predictions at
the individual level
how do we scale this up that's what got
me into psychometric AI which just to
kind of frame that I think is one part
of something larger that you could call
emotional AI or empathic AI and that's
how I found it pinpoint predictive yeah
this is so cool that when when you think
of things like a long term maybe like
let's say just 15-year perspective on
the tech explosion side of things so
you're here in the Bay Area and you're
what you're literally coming through
this period of time now over the last 15
years and it is it's so crazy like jaren
points out in this book as well that
this idea of data what are we gonna be
doing with this data how is culture
being shaped by this data and then you I
like how you starting to showcase to us
here that it's a lot of this is about
even empathic AI as you say psychometric
ai and empathic AI and now explain to us
more on you know your founding pinpoint
predictive yeah teach us more about this
yeah absolutely
so pinpoint predictive spun out of the
Stanford startx accelerator which which
is fantastic and it was founded to be to
bring to market the first privacy safe
psychometric AI to disrupt people
predictions what we're here to do and
one way that I like to look at this
there's kind of how does this make our
life better but there's this kind of
intellectual way they like to think
about it like our mission is to be an
inflection point in the relationship
between people and machines and we've
reached a point where there's a lot of
data cloud computing and very powerful
algorithms and data is all around us and
were entertained and
media and e-commerce and all these
different things different platforms
different apps but a lot of people have
the sense that they've been followed
around or tracked or stalked by
technology and that's true and that's
because behavioral targeting the most
data-driven ways or the most powerful
and predominant by people who are
serious about making people predictions
today and so the future is predicted
based on narrow past behaviors to even
the extent that future predictions are
transparently about the past you know
would you like to see this film well
kind of it's the most similar one to it
I just watched last night sure but
aren't there more interesting films I
could be watching so our mission is to
be that inflection point when between
the past and the present our machines
follow people and that point just
starting right now already and going
into the future
where machines start to understand us as
individuals and be able to make
forward-facing predictions and I think
that's incredibly exciting because it
can make our lives better and I'd love
to dive into that and I also think it's
exciting and a whole other level of
meaning for kind of moral and political
reasons that I'd be happy to to dive
into as well based on kind of where
things are in our country so that's I
mean obviously we're a business we and
we do commercial work but I think
focusing on the individual is a special
thing to do maybe it's a very American
thing to do and I feel like if we did
that a little bit more and celebrated
individualism maybe we'd be in a better
place than we are today and maybe if our
leaders did that a little bit more
instead of trying to reduce
individuality and put people into these
buckets in groups maybe we would value
our humanity
little bit more yeah that's that's well
said there's a there's this gorgeous
equilibrium the Nash equilibrium that I
feel is so where we're heading but we
definitely need to prop up the
individual and the individuals Beauty
their own sovereign tree their own
ability to maximize their potential
while simultaneously realizing that the
collective flourishing is is important
simultaneously so like knowing that
equilibrium moving forward is I think
you know where we're heading and I'm
excited to see how we get there and how
it ends up ends up actually prospering
okay - as we get to you know what you
what these exciting ways of making
things better are with what I love how
you just talked about this as an
inflection point because when you when
you speak about it in the way of an
inflection point it kind of gives us the
more of a realization that this I like
also how you called it an empathic AI
that for me to be able to understand how
I can best synergize with machine
intelligence it's super important moving
forward and so talking about it in that
sense is really beautiful I like how you
said that so tell us about how exactly
you guys pinpoint predictive help help
make things better you were talking
about also on the morality side of
things making things better so yeah
teach us about that sure there are ways
in which we're doing this today that we
have particular applications and I'd be
happy to go into them some of them are a
little bit Monday and I think they're
fascinating when when you get into the
into some of the details but to describe
this at kind of a bigger level and talk
about empathic AI I'd like to start at
that place because that's the level at
which we can really answer the question
how can my life be better through
technology and let's start with the
premise that you know life is difficult
we're in this simulation well I think
maybe we should see what our different
definitions are at some point but I
definitely feel comfortable that word is
a kind of
biological reality but we're in this
strange human condition and it's very
hard for us to predict the future I
don't know exactly what's going on in
your head right now I feel imagine
because it's full of brilliant ideas and
you're exposed to so much and the weird
human condition as you said it the
strangeness of being in this biological
world that we find yeah I don't know
what the next sense it's gonna come out
of your mouth I don't know the next one
that's gonna come out of my mouth it's
very hard to predict the future and yet
we feel like we're we have this agency
we feel like we're making decisions and
there's a lot of things that don't come
out in the way that we expect and people
have been having these thoughts for
thousands of years about you know life
life is hard the basic basic idea now
today we can talk about that in terms of
prediction and data but people
acknowledge this for very long time why
is life hard life is hard because we
don't because of that fundamental reason
among many other reasons right but it's
hard because we have to do certain
things we we have most people have to
work they have to choose what to study
what's the right career what company
should they work for who should they
have a professional relationship with a
personal relationship what products
should they buy what experience will
make them happy and people get it wrong
over and over and over again
so you know and there's a lot of pain
that comes out of that and it's hard to
admit that no most people don't like to
admit that you know they could have done
something in a more optimal way that
would have reduced their suffering great
more happiness now it's very easy to
think of relationships or their little
failures that we go through in life but
let me pull up something that's more
interesting than that and more mundane
at the same time you know the you you
know all kinds of amazing fields an
interesting field so so positive
psychology where psychology starts to
use kind of scientific and quantitative
methods to research the question of
happiness what makes people happy well
it turns out that the consensus was that
buying things for ourselves doesn't
really make us happier true if you if I
buy you a present I'll get more
happiness out of that or if I buy an
experience identification that tends to
increase life satisfaction which which
is a psychometric by the way but buying
things for yourself doesn't so that's
weird now why does that happen yeah well
there wasn't a complete answer until
recently when someone who's a digital
psychometrician named one of our
colleagues on the academic side named
Sandra Matz she did research showing
that when you control for personality
and match the products of most
personality that they'll spend more on
this brand and though that will actually
measurably increase their life
satisfaction and what does this say this
says two things actually very
interesting is number one we're so bad
at making predictions that when we buy
stuff for ourselves we get it wrong just
as much as we get it right and and you
can kind of pull memories ahead and in
fact check this with your own intuition
there are things you can remember that
you felt happy with and things that kind
of bummed you out because why did I
spend money on this right and that's
because it's hard for us to make
predictions there's with that what the
first one I totally was feeling what you
were saying
with man giving gifts is happiness when
I go and get things for myself not only
are we stumped when thinking sometimes
looking through like the electronic tea
kettle section on Amazon or on a store
we're just like which one of these
things do I even get which one of these
do I want
well I later I realized that I don't
want the ones that have just a metal
container I want the one that has a
glass container I want to be able to see
the water level more clearly I want some
cool LED lights on the bottom these are
just some interesting strange things
that you realize after maybe several
cycles of purchasing like electronic tea
kettles mm-hmm for your teas and coffees
and stuff don't even get me started on
when you go and like there's 50
different selections of jeans and like
dress shirts and stuff like that so
which ones do I want well I like color I
like color a lot and I like to stand out
so now is there a way to make things
like pinpoint predictive be able to
realize better Oh Allen wants styles of
electronics like this or styles of
clothing like that and just make it so I
don't have to go through this process of
trying to figure [ __ ] out yeah
absolutely yeah that's exactly what we
do is there are behavioral ways to
figure things out like Alan took a
digital behavior and let's show an ad
for that or and that's what happens
today and people feel followed around by
the tea kettle if you'll fall around by
the lawnmower after they already made a
decision and they're not gonna buy
another tea kettle for a group for quite
some time
or there's the the film example it's
forward-looking but it's so
transparently and narrowly based on the
past that it's not the most interesting
film that you could be watching in that
moment where as a psychological
recommender system works as well or
better than the behavior one but it says
oh we think you're gonna like this
because I'm speaking
as if as if in the consciousness of and
you know an artificial intelligence or
machine learning right we've looked at
billions and billions of data points and
statistical patterns and you're very
similar and numerous psychological
dimensions that people who like the tea
kettle that has the the blue light and
you can see the water and maybe you
should get to know this tea kettle
sooner in your in your tea kettle
adventure in life and you'll get more
happiness sooner from that that's right
yeah stuff like that that's okay cool um
that this is very important did you
remember the second part I completely
forgot but I'm sure some other it will
some ideas will come around okay okay I
just wanted to check in about that
thanks okay and then I just well now
let's keep playing on this point because
I think this point super interesting
this idea that if we can sort of realize
that there have been a hundred billion
humans before us that built civilization
and they've all had exposure to these
different stimuli Zin this biological
reality that we live in and then we can
understand certain junctures that these
hundred billion humans have went through
in their life that depending on the
things that they enjoy and depending on
the junctures that they've been at that
then similar ideas like on a style of
electronic that one may enjoy etc
getting exposed to those things at an
earlier point in their life adventure in
their life story is better and so yeah
give us these examples more on these
examples on pinpoint predictive because
you put us in your shoes of your your
machine learning psychometric power
system give us more thoughts on these
examples and the relatability that they
can have for bettering our lives
I think reducing the suffering that
happens when there's a mismatch a
difference in expectation of what will
make us happy compared with what
actually does whether it's something as
mundane as a tea kettle or something
insignificant
a relationship or a career or any of
those important decisions so they're
hard to make and going back together
idea about all the people that came
before I'd like to borrow an idea from
you've all her re yep and in particular
from a talk that he gave at Google a few
years back and he made a very
provocative kind of statement that I
think is one of the more interesting and
important things he said there's a lot
of interesting things of course a lot of
people are interested what he has to say
and and I had the privilege of getting
to know his work a little while a little
bit in the past and got to write a
review and the washington post of
sapiens and why I was doing that I was
actually already doing pinpoint
predictive and so I watched this talk
that he gave at Google and he said
something incredible which is that in
the development of humanity there's been
a shift in the locus of that authority
kind of ultimate authority and it used
to be and of course we don't really live
in some kind of linear uniform time when
I say used to be it still is like all of
these are still true right like you know
there's a lot of things in life that are
like that religion is one of them we
have this ideas like a religion as this
go here anything but a lot of things
that people believe come from actually
different things like a lot of people
believe in ghosts all right a lot of
people believe in good and evil and a
lot of things get syncretized and it's
the same thing here with you you've all
her Arya's idea I'm actually gonna get
to hopefully which is that that look
that transfer of locus so that the first
one they mentions is religious authority
mm-hmm
where that's the highest authority and
of course in many places and cultures it
still is and then he says in cultures
that went through the Enlightenment
that changed and
they became more individualism and
there's more human intuition right and
unless let's talk about mate choice cuz
mate choice is something that I've
written about a lot mate mate choice
like who we choose to correct to breed
with reproduce reproduce yeah so so make
choices I'm gonna thread this into his
argument as I as I push it forward
because it's fun to think about it's
it's less abstract so in very religious
societies mate choice is influenced by
the religious view of the world when
who's supposed to reproduce with him and
even who makes the influences the
decision and how much it has to do with
certain groups or you know gas or
astrological signs all kinds of yeah
it's interesting you could talk for
hours about that but then when you go
from religion to that sort of post
enlightenment individualism its
intuition and love marriage and only you
know best and what conserve ASTs your
own intuition your own self knowledge
interesting right that's that's been
dominant and now we're being challenged
yeah again that's right right our data
yeah there's so much predictive
psychometric AI driven potential for
formate choice right whoa
right so so now our human narcissism is
being challenged and I think maybe it
was I don't remember who said this and I
forgetting who said this but they said
that you know Darwin challenged our
narcissism by comparing us with animals
and and Freud did it saying that he goes
not quite the master of its own house
and I don't know maybe I forgot the
the ancient astronomer Galileo Galileo
did it we were not the center of the
universe
maybe Freud was the person who brought
this up and he was at the end of that
but anyway just just another fun
parallel history and science and the
history of science has some patterns
where it challenges us to confront our
kind of our narcissism as human beings
of our sense of control or sense that we
we know so much and that the idea that
the ancient Greek philosopher was it
Socrates talking about I know a lot
because I know what I don't know yeah I
mean that's deep that's deep with still
something to think about huge hugely
important hugely important are knowing
the extent of our own ignorance so a
crucial right I feel really really
privileged have gotten a lot of time to
dive into some feels some particular
areas out to the edges of them when we
go out to the edge of the field and you
have to create new knowledge it's very
humbling because you're you're looking
out over the edge and you say I know
this area really really well and that's
the end of the world for now something's
gonna come up it's not the end of
history but that's the end of knowledge
right now and that's humbling and
building a company it is humbling it's
it's it's it's a team sport and it's an
extreme sport it's about collaboration
and so I love thinking about these kind
of ideas so we are challenged and this
comes up a lot there's a lot of anxiety
that people have today about the
relationship with technology I think
people are kind of questioning their own
freewill a little bit and not and people
don't have I don't want to over
generalize that's a that's a bad thing
to do I think there's a lot of people
that haven't thought maybe deeply enough
questions of agency or or will and they
have kind of some some fears about this
that for me are interesting and and this
comes up a lot this kind of
free-floating angst and you know and
social media and and so on and so forth
creates kind of a lot of questions so
anyway it's it's very interesting to be
right in the middle of that and to be a
company that's founded first and
foremost on privacy safety of going
above and beyond that for many reasons
and explaining the benefits of
forward-facing predictions and and what
is privacy safety mean like well it it
there let's get there in just a quick
moment I cuz I have this point that you
said about human narcissists who is so
interesting we've had this over and over
again cycle back where our hubris is so
a heads up being so visible we were just
overly excessively confident in our own
in our own thinking that oh yeah there's
the center of the universe or you know
or oh here we go into the next era where
psychometric powered AI knows out of
seven point eight billion people well
yeah these are the best candidates for
you for potentially your mate
mm-hm and that's crazy interesting and
it's it's humbling because you don't
necessarily have to spend all these bad
mistakes like with the tea kettle or
with a clothing option of whatever these
these these examples are because if we
remember when we were younger we had
these fun little in class in your school
at times you would take these like who
do you match with best denier in your
school as like as again one of these
psychometric tests and it was you know
the kindergarten in comparison of an AI
powered cycle metrics but it was very
interesting nonetheless to be able to
see these things so I just I love
your point about about narcissism and
also about agency was very interesting
as well
how much agency how often do we actually
how much agency do we have how often do
we look at ourselves in the mirror and
aim to say how much agency do I have how
much how much should I give up to things
that are better than the hewed this
strange human condition that we have so
it's it's very exciting stuff so now
okay now teach us about the the privacy
safe side of the psychometric ai okay
well thanks on that I'd love to dive
into that issue and I promise you that I
will kick that you just stimulated too
much hey cool ideas in my head okay get
up hit us I'd like to say something
we're talking about narcissism I hope I
hope it's not narcissistic but I'm a
human being so I you know what can you
do like we all have some some level that
I guess and here's what I think so I
have kind of a funny story and I could
tell you though what the underlying
logic is later on maybe at the end what
I think it is but it's a funny story
because when I when I was an undergrad
it was I remember like 2000 2001 and I
had this roommate back in college
and he had like a surfer farm in her
room and he was sitting there you know I
was like sleeping in kind of doing the
young people thing and he was like doing
business deals and the economy's booming
and people were dropping out and IPOs
and stuff and I was setting up the
apology and learning you know writing
about humor in an indigenous language
and I was like the last person in the
world you'd expect to be sitting here
talking about technology so it's an
interesting story and for me I feel
there's there's a gap there there's a
massive gap to cross and here's here's
the narcissistic part but I think it's
interesting that that maybe I could put
some ideas together that you know span
across areas like evolutionary
anthropology and
you know I've worked in a lot of
developing countries and in political
environments that worked with different
or I've lived in Washington DC for a
while and there's there's a huge gap
between Washington and Silicon Valley
there's a huge gap between Silicon
Valley and the world and I love reading
the media and seeing how people like to
criticize stuck-on Valley and I feel
like there's a lot of interesting
motivations and some of it's very
legitimate and some of it's completely
on the other side of a disconnect but I
guess the point I'm trying to get to
here is that technology is challenging
us and from because of my background
because of the work I've done in
behavioral biology that's similar in
some regard to work of someone like
Robert Sapolsky although he's obviously
been doing this for a very long time and
more accomplished but but what's
interesting is we would come to some
similar conclusions and I think these
technology is like a foil if I'm using
that in the right way it's like it's
like this weird kind of mirror mm-hmm
and I don't think it has to be a black
mirror I think that that's that shows
really dark it's interesting yeah but
it's a mirror and it it reveals things
about ourselves yes and we put we
project onto that mirror and people feel
anxious about this question of their
agency that's what I wanted to get back
to yeah and that has nothing nothing to
do with technology and it does at the
same time yeah how's that possible
well people have been worrying about
their agency yeah since there's records
of people thinking this is an ancient
question
in civilizations you know in different
parts of the world like people been it's
it's it's a problem it's a problem in
religion I mean in in in in every
successful large religion it's a problem
I mean that's that's you could pull up
an idea like karma for example if
something good happens Mir bad happens
to me is that because of my good
intention now or my bad intention now or
is it because of something that happened
in the past the the happen was good or
bad it's like it's like psychologically
indeterminate and it there's there's
people been struggling with this in the
East in the West and technology is
challenging us in new ways and making a
lot of people have some anxiety about
this question of agency that's an old
question yeah it's as old as our biology
and I think it's really really
interesting and when you think about it
more deeply some interesting things
happen it doesn't there's can be kind of
more freedom or more liberation yeah
that's right so I love diving deep into
these challenging areas yeah and
figuring out how can Silicon Valley kind
of get a better perspective on itself
and do something good in the world
rather than just coming up with crazy
ideas and not thinking about the
consequences of of what that means amen
that's right and technology challenging
agencies a fascinating three word OOP
phrase I like that a lot
all right let's do privacy safe yeah
thank you Ron
privacy safe psychometric okay let's
talk about that insure addictive yeah so
the idea of modeling people
psychologists it's a powerful thing to
be able to do and it requires some
powerful safeguards so we were founded
around patent-pending technology that
allows us to be more privacy safe than a
lot of the other kind of tech platforms
out there today and to make this very
simple and some aspect we don't have any
personal identifiable real names or
contact information we don't allow that
to go into our environment at all and
that's one important area that that
makes it privacy safe and also we use
psychology to make predictions for
approved business use cases we don't
we're not like a data provider that
sells data on people we don't do that we
use we build models to understand the
reasons why people engage and then make
complex optimizations that protect
people's data but get to a business
result that's positive to make people's
lives better so there's there's
something there that I thought was
really interesting that that you that
separately that separates you both that
there's this this this strong not non no
personal identifier side of things and
then the other thing is the is the
business cases these business decisions
that you guys get to make with the
incoming requests is that you guys get
to pick what you want to say yes to so
that it's not simply whoever comes gets
to work with you
that's correct very important yeah yeah
yeah so again just to recap one is not
having any any personal and if I won't
finish so we won't even touch social
media data at all because it's connected
to people's names and
it's kind of a been problematic area
recently you know we can still you know
leverage that media and do interesting
things with that now the other thing is
we because we're not like a data
provider we won't say oh here's a group
of you know here's a group of depressed
teenagers on Facebook and sell that to
everybody and just wait sonic terrible
happens right it's a horrible recipe for
disaster
good thing to do but if say an important
you know if the National Institutes of
Health wants to help people and so you
know good group reputable then yes we
look at an objective which is how can
you help people because the objective
shouldn't be I'd like to buy a scan of
data because there's a privacy problem
and there's also an efficiency problem
so our technology if they were to come
and say you know we could measure
exactly how much more you know of X Y Z
traits people are and many other things
that people don't even think of it so
the fun thing about social scientific
data science is there's always like
these three levels of findings there's
the obvious stuff there is the stuff
that's not obvious but it makes sense
and it answers questions and then
there's the curly fries category
what's the curly curly fries category is
like the kind of WTF category it's curly
fries in the early research in this
field was found to correlate with high
IQ interest and it wasn't like a
spurious weird artifact of just a few
people liking curly fries you know all
that stuff is controlled for I don't
know if anyone has a hypothesis of what
curly fries you know it's easier to
explain why people like Mozart it's you
know whether you know that's just what
the data science says or science or
the sound of Morgan Freeman's voice
mm-hmm is surely it's with thank you it
may be people who watch a lot of
documentaries and that's correlated with
Morgan Freeman narrating them sure like
to consume more knowledge yes that's
what social science data science looks
like yes and we're in a fun area because
we look at the individual whereas social
science today has a lot of ideological
biases where they only look at it a
couple of groups in averages and that's
a problem it's it's it's a huge huge
ideological problem because business
today needs to make predictions about
people and we need predictions that are
gonna help us that are individualized to
us but social science needs to go
further it can't just focus on you know
all men versus all women or average like
like behavioral economics is a
fascinating field but I have to
criticize it a little bit because it's
great to know that on average we have
these rationalities although from an
evolutionary point of view they've
become a little bit less irrational but
anyway but how do you operationalize
that like what is person a is you know
level like what is the variance in the
rationality there are different people
how do you build models do make real
predictions and have real business
results that's where that field needs to
go that's right yeah you have this the
social sciences of the individual and
the psychometric profiles of those
individuals is very fascinating in the
way that they engage in their in these
this biological environment that we play
in and being at this field like I like
your point earlier about being at the
edge when you're at the edge of
knowledge there's a lot of hubris
there's a lot of hubris and that you got
to be very careful you have to be humble
you have to be humble just in case why
ending important I think being at the
edge is there's a cure for hubris it's a
cure for hubris yeah totally
but being humble at the same time
sometimes it's
we can get overly confident in our echo
chambers of edge and there's a lot of
issues that can happen with
disseminating the knowledge to the youth
that are coming up that we need to get
better at in education etc okay two
questions on the way out
obby first question is what is the core
driving principle of your life well in
two parts I mean one kind of used has
been one has been I'm the kind of person
that really likes complex systems you
know it's funny my mom was telling me
about when I was a kid and what my
favorite toy was and I'm glad she
brought it back so brought back these
fond memories that were hidden inside of
my head had forgotten but they were like
these Japanese boxes think like the
Russian dolls but way cooler different
colors different shapes there's like one
inside of another inside of another I've
always loved iterations you know I've
loved depent I'd love like clauses
inside of clauses and language I like
that you know if you're if you're
building something and I like
understanding of very complex systems
fit together and be able to see the
whole better and faster and getting
there getting there sooner so there is
no perfect person in the world to write
a science book about heritable
psychometric traits I mean it had it
covered too much ground but I felt like
I was as good as person as they need to
give it a try and when I understood that
more powerful forward facing privacy
safe interpretable and efficient people
predictions were possible there could be
a scientific standard people data to
compare people on something meaningful
and predictive and that to be done I
wanted to get there first so that's the
first part of the answer but the second
part is actually implementing it you
know I had to it's much more of a team
sport so that changed my perspective a
lot yeah you know collaboration is an
interesting thing it's it's I think that
pushes people to grow and to get people
with such different expertise to work
together on something very complex and
and to kind of give it back and forth
the different expertise is a beautiful
thing and it's and it's a difficult
thing and it's something that's
necessary for progress yeah hobby this
isn't such a fun show I really
appreciate you coming on and teaching us
about pinpoint predictive cycle metric
AI it's been a lot of fun thank you so
thank you thanks for having me it's been
a blast thanks everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below on
what we were talking about let us know
get that community rolling also check
out the links below to pinpoint
predictive go and check them out and
much love support the artists and
entrepreneurs that you believe in
support them help them grow also build
the future everyone shout out to Ron for
producing and directing the show we love
you all so much and we will see you soon
you